Donald Trump is trying to go after the
Hispanic vote increasingly we know that
he has said he loves his
african-americans as he has pointed to
people in the crowd by the way the guy
he referred to as my african-american he
I guess is no longer a Republican so
that didn't go super well and Donald
Trump now trying to appeal to Hispanic
and Latino voters Trump did a campaign
rally yesterday in New Mexico the idea
was let's show up there and let's talk
about how low Hispanic unemployment is
and how great everything is and it went
about as poorly as you would expect
first of all bad poll after bad poll for
Donald Trump in some key swing states
for 2020
eight years of tax returns subpoenaed as
I already told you about new corruption
investigation into Trump's
Transportation Secretary who happens to
be Mitch McConnell's wife Elaine Chao so
Trump in the midst of all this shows up
in New Mexico and tries to appeal to
Hispanic voters sort of in the same way
that he tried to appeal to black voters
in 2016 which is blaming other people
for things and citing incorrect
statistics the clips are genuinely hard
to watch but also kind of fun listen to
Trump here as he talks about the
Hispanics as he refers to them by so
where the Hispanic American the
Hispanics were up with me in a poll 17%
and everyone said how is that
[Applause]
up by 70% I won't even tell you what the
final number was because they won't
believe it but you're gonna see what the
final number but you know why because
the hispanic-americans
they understand they don't want
criminals coming across the border they
don't want people taking their jobs they
want to have that security and they want
the wall they want the wall taking their
jobs it's truly hilarious that they
still use that stupid debunked bogus
talking point meant to completely
exculpate big corporations from the
immigration low wage status quo that
persists here in the United States and
more importantly the bigger lie there
Donald Trump claiming that Hispanics
want the border wall it's like no they
don't most of the country doesn't want
the border wall and if you're looking
specifically at Hispanic voters they we
I should say as part of that group we
don't want the border wall I mean
completely and totally untrue Trump also
heckled yesterday a bunch of times I was
only able in the time I had to prep this
morning I was only able to pull one clip
where you hear the heckling going on
Trump doing all the normal attempts to
attempt to appeal to Hispanic voters
you'll hear him getting heckled after
the initial applause line here in the
background Trump just continues talking
over it and actually does successfully
yesterday marked the beginning of the
Hispanic Heritage Month who is Hispanic
here
Latinos fitrah
credible people but we have much to
celebrate unbelievable when you think
the unemployment for Hispanic Americans
is right now at the lowest level ever
recorded in the history of our country
Hispanic American poverty reached a
brand-new all-time low in history and
after years of stagnation that you know
very well wages for Hispanic Americans
are rising really fast up nearly 8
percent since my election those are
unheard of numbers and medium income
think of that median income for Hispanic
Americans surpassed $50,000 for the
first time ever so this is the same type
of pandering that we've seen from Donald
Trump before yes the polls don't look
good among Hispanics for Donald Trump or
in these swing states but the only poll
that matters in the end is how people
actually go and vote in November of 2020
if they actually choose to vote so
despite all this pandering despite all
this rambling and all of it that man
that you just saw talking about
Hispanics and lying about the wall he
can still win in 2020 on autopilot if we
do not show up how a Hispanic voter
speaking as a Hispanic voter myself can
support Donald Trump at this point I
don't know and the rallies make it even
more confusing patronizing marginalized
and minority communities in the most
obviously transparent ways the
supporters are totally cringe worthy
it's an international embarrassment and
it actually in the end may all work to
get the guy reelected that's just the
the sole focus needs to be no matter how
cartoonish the clips I play for you no
matter how unbelievable and erratic and
and bogus are the claims that Donald
Trump makes he can get reelected in 2020
and he
do it even if his approval rating drops
10 points mathematically that is and so
in the end all that matters is that we
actually go and vote in November of 2020
and get as many people as possible to go
and do the same thing make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show and while
you are there follow me on instagram at
david pakman we'll take a quick break
and back with oliver thorn from
philosophy tube right after this I want
to tell you about one of our sponsors
called the Menlo Club a men's fashion
community that provides carefully
curated style packages for any type of
guy and they're giving you as a David
Pakman show viewer your first box for
$35 off when you click the link
underneath this video or go to their
site and use the promo code Pakman as a
member of the Menlo Club you receive
delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of two items
often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at